j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public je vous propose un gros plan sur
un acteur peut-être discret mais majeur
de ce conflit au ProcheOrient le Qatar
comment cette petite monarchie du golf
peut-elle à la fois être l'allié
économique des États-Unis de plusieurs
pays occidentaux la France y compris et
le pays qui abrite les dirigeants du
ramas on explique ce grand écart dans un
instant avec nos invités mais d'abord
Fabien Requet retrace le rôle des
dirigeants qatari depuis le 7
octobre ces deux américaines étaient
aage du Hamas leur libération vendre
filmé ici par le groupe terroriste a été
obtenu grâce à une médiation du Qatar le
Qatar que le secrétaire d'État américain
s'est empressé de saluer je veux
remercier le gouvernement du Qatar pour
son assistance très importante
négociateur dans la libération des otage
mais aussi convoyeur de l'aide
humanitaire à Gaza depuis le début de la
crise au Proche Orient le Qatar s'est
rendu indispensable fort de sa capacité
à parler à tout le monde ami des
États-Unis dont l'émirat héberge une
base milita
mais aussi amis du Hamas c'est depuis
DEA qu'Ismaël anier le chef politique de
l'organisation prend la parole depuis le
début du conflit comme le 7 octobre jour
de l'attaque terroriste en territoire
israélien nous sommes sur le point de
remporter une grande victoire à une
nette conquête sur le front de Gaza mais
entre DOA et le Hamas les liens sont
surtout financiers chaque mois le
richissime état gazier verse 30 millions
de dollars à l'administration du Hamas
pour payer les salaires de ses
fonctionnaires à Gaza et financer des
CHCs alimentaires pour la population une
proximité qui Vaute au Qatar
l'accusation de financer le terrorisme
le Qatar rend des services mais cette
proximité presque cette consanguinité
avec le Hamas ça interroge à tel point
qu'on peut se demander si parfois il
jouent pas double jeu on l'a vu en Syrie
où il y avait quasiment des lignes
directes avec le Fran et nousra filial
del Khalida
ou il pren les otages le Qatar libéré
payer les rançons il y avit une espèce
d'écosystème un petit peu malsin tout ça
pour avoir pour avoir le B rôle
finalement et pour jouer son s power
mais c'est vrai que c'est critiqué c'est
critiquable jusqu'à un certain point
parce que obligé aujourd'hui on on a
besoin d'eux un art du grand écart
diplomatique sur fond de puissance
énergétique l'mira vient de signer
plusieurs accords gaziers à long terme
avec la France l'Italie ou encore
l'Allemagne on analyse on décortique le
rôle du Qatar dans ce conflit avec agès
Levallois bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
spécialiste du Moyen-Orient
vice-présidente de l'Institut de
recherche et d'études Méditerranée
Moyen-Orient myiam benrad bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes politologue
spécialiste du Moyen-Orient professeur
en relation internationale à
l'Université Internationale Schiller et
vous publiez l'état islamique est-il
défit aux éditions du CNRS Quentin müer
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous aussi
rédacteur en chef adjoint du service
international du magazine Marianne et
co-auteur de ce livre Les esclave de
l'homme pétrole aux éditions martiali
Laeti crupa est resté à mes côtés
évidemment peut-être un peu de pédagogie
tout simplement pour commencer on va
regarder une carte ça fait du bien de
regarder une carte de la région le Qatar
pays de 11500 km² de superficie c'est
quoi un peu plus grand que la Gironde
comme puissant voisin l'Arabie Saoudite
et de l'autre côté du golf persique
l'Iran pays très riche évidemment
produit intérieur butre estimé à 237
milliards de dollars en 2022 c'est le 6e
revenu par habitant le plus élevé au
monde agès Levallois côté institution
quel portrait politique peut ton dressé
du du Qatar c'est une monarchie
religieuse on peut dire ça comme ça oui
monarchie religieuse autoritaire dans le
sens où il y a une famille et a un émir
qui gère le le pays qui a pas beaucoup
de contestation puisque vous avez que
300000 nationaux sur un million
d'habitants donc on est vraiment dans un
tout tout petit pays où les conditions
de vie sont telles que les Qatariens
n'ont pas tellement envie de remettre en
cause le système qui est proposé par
lesmire il y a eu quelques contestations
lors des soulèvements en 2011 et donc il
y a quand même un poète qui a osé é
mettre quelques critiques qui a été
emprisonné immédiatement et vous avez à
côté de ça la fameuse chaîne de
télévision aljazira qui a beaucoup fait
parler d'elle qui a été créée par le
Qatar et qui a vraiment révolutionné le
paysage médiatique du monde arabe
puisque c'était une chaîne de télévision
et c'est encore une chaîne qui est très
libre dans ses propos avec quelques
lignes rouges quand même une des
principales c'est qu'on ne parle pas du
Qatar et c'est un pays qui n'a de cesse
que d'essayer de se distinguer d'avoir
sa propre autonomie par rapport
justement à l'Arabie Saoudite puisque
l'Arabie Saoudite est le poids lourd de
la région côté arabe et et que le
l'Arabie Saoudite entend être le leader
au sein de ce qu'on appelle le Conseil
de Coopération du golf qui regroupe les
six pétromonarchies du golf et que le
Qatar mène sa propre politique et on le
voit bien dans votre reportage en
justement créant cette chaîne de
télévision aljazira ça a été le premier
acte vraiment d'autonomie et puis en
soutenant les Frères musulmans je pense
qu'on va y revenir au grand d'â des
Émirats arabes unis et dans une moindre
mesure de l'Arabie Saoudite et donc le
Qatar grâce à sa richesse grâce à ses
ressources enant avoir sa propre
stratégie ce qui énerve beaucoup
beaucoup ses voisins et en particulier
l'Arabie Saoudite et les Émirats et qui
sont allés jusqu'à accuser le Qatar
d'être trop proche de l'Iran et ce qui a
conduit un blocus qui a été mis en place
en 2017 sans aucun résultat pour le
Qatar qui grâce à ses ressources a pu
faire venir des vages Australie pour
contourner le le blocus et créer ses
propres ressources et d'être venu grâce
à ça de sa manière autosuffisante ouis
MIREM benrad si si on parle un peu plus
de la de la société peut-être de la des
femmes au Qatar est-ce que c'est
comparable à l'Arabie Saoudite par
exemple bah c'est je dirais que le Qatar
enfin pour compléter ce que ce qu'agè
Levallois a dit c'est c'est vrai que
c'est quand même un pays de de paradoxe
he parce que c'est un un pays qui a
connu ce boom évidemment économique du
fait de la rente gazière le pays est
assis sur des des ressources pour plus
de de siècles donc c'est énorme il y a
eu une diversification de l'économie le
développement enfin ils ont pris pour
modèle Dubaï donc donc le développement
de tout un un secteur tertiire très
important donc on a une modernité très
exubérante très poussée très avancé
exubérante qui côtoi tout de même oui
des réflexes
conservateurs le poids des traditions
donc les femmes sont je DIRIS que c'est
très inégal on va avoir des femmes bon
de la société locale qui reste quand
même prisonnière comme je viens de le
dire d'une certaine tradition religieuse
sociale ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu' elles peuvent
très basique est-ce qu'elles peuvent
conduire est-ce qu'ell conduire
c'est pas l'Arabie Saoudite non plus si
vous voulez enfin quoi que l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est quand même beaucoup
réformé c'est un peu réformé bon donc
bon ça ça va vraiment dépendre du milieu
on a aussi toute la société étrangère
hein parce qu'on a des sociétés
parallèles au Qatar on a les expatriés
donc c'est c'est comme je l'ai dit j'ai
comparé quand même avec Dubaï parce que
c'est vraiment le modèle que DOA a pris
pendant un certain temps donc c'est un
pays de paradoxe on a encore une fois
cette modernité euh très avancée très
vraiment très très surprenante et euh et
c'est restes de tradition mais je je
vais quand même finir là-dessus des
restes parce que ce qui est quand même
assez frappant c'est qu'il y a pas
vraiment de mémoire en fait au Qatar moi
c'est ce qui m'avait frappé quand j'ai
découvert le qataar alors c'était il y a
longtemps moi j'ai découvert quand même
le qataar il y a 20 ans donc c'était
déjà développé mais ça continuait de
pousser un peu dans tous les sens dévele
rapidement ou et et et mais il y avait
cette absence de mémoire de rapport à à
à l'avant d'accord et ça ça pose
question quand même par rapport je pense
quand même à ce qui est l'histoire ce
qui est devenu l'histoire du Qatar
récemment y compris sur le plan
diplomatique polique al justement on va
y venir sur le plan diplomatique et
politique mais une dernière question
quanttin muler sur la famille régnante
et alttan qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de
cette famille de sa légitimité politique
en quelque sorte sa légitimité politique
ne repose que sur la redistribution des
rentes gazières et pétrolières
c'est-à-dire que c'est une famille qui a
pris le pouvoir qui s'est qui a saisi ce
ce pouvoir là et c'est un espèce de
pacte tacite avec la population c'est on
redistribue les richesses on devient un
état ultra Providence c'est-à-dire que
l'éducation l'électricité l'eau euh le
le la santé tout ça enfin les les les
cataristes sont exonérés de payer tout
ça puis surtout même on leur donne des
avantages énorme c'estàdire que quand un
catar esté tout de suite il a un compte
en banque qui est ouvert avec de
l'argent dessus on lui attribue des
terres et cetera et en échange de ça la
population n'a rien à dire vis-à-vis de
la la la politique intérieure et
étrangère du Qatar et ça c'est la
famille régnante à qui qui décide de ça
donc le le la légitimité euh de la
famille rayante elle est je dirais elle
est fragile puisque on l'a vu vous
l'avez très bien dit pendant les
printemps arabes il y a eu quelques
contestations et tout de suite le pays
s'est fermé et et a et a réprimé euh les
les voix les les rares voix discordantes
donc il y a pas une possibilité de
critique au Qatar et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'Al jaasira parle très peu
des des soucis internes euh je veux dire
en terme dictatorial de de de ce pays h
alors il y a il y a ce paradoxe apparent
hein et à la fois euh euh les
investissements dans les pays
occidentaux euh les Alliés économiques
des États-Unis en passant par la France
beaucoup de pays d'Europe et puis il y a
effectivement la question du financement
des organisations terroristes je
commence par cette question de
financement et je reste avec vous
Quentin
müer quelles organisations terroristes
sont financées par le Hamas aujourd'hui
alors terroriste c'est un peu Qatar vous
voulez dire par le Qatar l'absus
intéressant merci de m'avoir repris par
le Qatar aujourd'hui comme d'autres pays
du Golf a tendance à livrer tout un tas
de de d'aide financières en tout cas à
beaucoup de
d'organisations des milices des
organisations islamiques plus ou moins
fréquentable alors je vais être plus
précis est-ce que l'État islamique a
touché ou touche de l'argent alors au
départ de de la Révolution sirrienne il
y a eu des groupes comme alnosra qui ont
pu toucher de l'argent directement ou
indirectement de la la part de Catari
qui avait plus ou moins de enfin qui
plus ou moins de contact avec la famille
régnante distribué avec
quelle en fait ce sont des tout ça est
très trouble en fait ce sont des des si
vous voulez des canaux financiers qui
sont difficilement traçable avec des des
des intermédiaires et cetera où l'argent
est envoyé à des organisations
caritatives pour soutenir des
groupuscules islamiques qui ont qui qui
vont troubler certaines Dict arabe qui
ne qui ne convient pas à la vision un
peu conservatrice et wabite de de de la
famille régnante qatari qui est enfin
qui est wabite mais qui est proche aussi
des des mouvements Frères musulmans donc
ça c'est une partie de la réponse
l'autre partie c'est la question du du
Hamas agès Levallois alors là aussi on
peut essayer d'être précis c'est c'est
beaucoup d'argent on a on a recherché le
chiffre c'est 30 millions de dollars par
mois au Hamas pour payer les
fonctionnaires c'est ça alors le le
Hamas à la demande d'e certaine manière
des Israéliens puisque la situation de
la bande de Gaza est complètement
bloquée il y a ce blocus qui empêche
donc la situation économique est
dramatique et donc le système qui a été
trouvé pour éviter que ça n'explose
c'est de maintenir un niveau de survie
pour lequel en fait on a demandé au
Qatar de financer les salaires des
fonctionnaires de gazas qui permet de
faire vivre une partie de la de la
population et donc le Qatar qui soutient
le Hamas puisque le Qatar est le pays
qui soutient les Frères musulmans à
travers le monde et qui accueille
d'ailleurs à Doha et un certain nombre
de responsables du Hamas qui ne peuvent
plus être à Gaza ou en Palestine qui
habite à Doha et donc Doha c'est la
spécialité finalement sa marque de
fabrique c'est de soutenir les
mouvements Frères musulmans à travers le
monde et de rendre service c'est-à-dire
que quand on a besoin de trouver une
solution on se tourne vers le Qatar et
là en l'occurrence à Gaza puisque la
situation économique est catastrophique
et bien il y a eu ce deal si je puux
dire qui a été passé
aation des israli pour que tous lesis a
des valises qui arrivent avec 30
millions effectivement de dollars pour
payer les les salaires des fonctionnaire
est-ce qu'on sait myan si cet argent est
en grande partie détourné par le Hamas
enfin détourner c'est accusations de
corruptionah c'est c'est
alorsf je dirais a
le les C versements d'argent qui sont
fait donc pour des motifs spécifique
rémunérer les fonctionnaires et cetera
al parler de détournement ça voudrait
dire qu'on détourne de de de enfin
finalement de encore une fois de de
points ou de centre d'affectation dont
on n'est pas du tout sûr en réalité pour
commencer par ailleurs enfin non mais
derrière ma question c'est est-ce que
cet argent a servi à préparer oui
clairement le H le Hamas est au pouvoir
dans la bande de Gaza et le Hamas qu' ve
avec cetent en fait bah bien sûr enfin
ils sont c'est un mouvement armé qui
gouverne mais qui reste quand même sur
une une lutte je dirais arm enfin qui
n'a jamais renoncé depuis en réalité ces
ces attaques bon qui ont été très
virulentes dans les années 90 jusqu'à la
seconde Intifada qui n'avait pas renoncé
à la lutte armée qui certes prend le
pouvoir dans la bande de Gaza il faut le
dire mais qui repart directement à la
confrontation avec Israël parce que tout
ça n'est pas nouveau donc je je suppose
que l'argent du Qatar bien sûr est venu
amplifier et bien les les moyens leurs
capacités même si je pense qu'il faut
quand même faire attention à ne pas non
plus tout centrer au r qar parce que
s'ils ont détourné comme vous le dites
de l'argent il y a aussi quand même
d'autres sources de financement
évidemment on va pas faire comme si
l'Iran n'existait pas c'est l'éléfant au
milieu de la pièce dans notre débat
l'Iran évidemment si vous voulez ça
c'est une politique clientéliste mais
qui mais qui existe dans le golf et dans
enfin dans d'autres pays du golf comme
les les Émirats ou l'Arabie Saoudite ces
pays à Rose pas seulement que le le le
Hamas ou des organisations terroristes
mais aussi tout un tas de de de
personnes clés personnages clés dans des
pays limitrophes dans les pays du
Moyen-Orient et et et donc ces forces-là
leur sont fidèle à un moment donné euh
où il y a besoin de enfin par exemple je
prends l'exemple du Yémen euh le Qatar a
donner depuis longtemps de l'argent au
parti politique àisla qui est un parti
frériste et qui aujourd'hui se bat pour
que le Yémen reste unifié et se bat
contre des forces séparatistes qui sont
elles-mêmes arrosées par les Émirats h
voyez donc euh le Qatar comme l'Arabie
saouditemirat place des pions un peu
partout donc et justement dans ce
rapport de force est-ce que le Qatar a
la même influence que l'Arabie Saoudite
bah ils essayent d'avoir la même
influence que l'Arabie Saoudite en tout
cas dansement factuellement alors c'est
c'est difficile à dire mais l'Arabie
Saoudite par exemple est en perte
d'influence au Yémen le Qatar l' aussi
un peu et les Émirats ont pris le dessus
donc voyez c'est c'est une espèce de de
de de rivalité d'influence un peu
partout il y a pas que au Yemen ou dans
parce que je pense ça correspond à ce
que je disais tout au début c'estàd que
le Qatar a besoin de se distinguer parce
qu'il est tellement petit il peut être
mangé du jour au LIR la carte d'ailleurs
quand VO sur carte c'est vraiment
significatif le Qatar malgré sa
puissance financière bien sûr il peut il
s très bien s'il y a trois attentats
terroristes au Qatar je veux dire c'est
c'est un état qui est tellement petit et
c'est une monarchie tenue par une
famille 300000 Qatariens vous imaginez
ce que c'est c'est rien mil 500000
habitants mais seulement 300000 catarien
c'est 1 million 1lion bon il y a on dit
10 % la d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
c'est pas si facile de trouver les les
chiffres du nabit P il y a 300 mettons
350000 catariens vous imaginez ce que
c'est face à l'Arabie saoudite où vous
avez 30 millions dont 20 millions de
saoudiens et je parle même pas de l'Iran
de l'autre côté du golf avec 80 millions
d'habitants donc on est dans un rapport
de force complètement asymétrique donc
le Qatar s'il veut exister il faut qu'il
trouve des moyens d'apparaître sur la
carte du monde et de s'imposer c'est ce
qu'il a fait avec la Coupe du monde de
football et qu'il avait fait auparavant
en soutenant des groupes euh qui des
groupes islamiste de la même obédience
religieuse parce que c'est un une
monarchie où habite et donc il va
soutenir des groupes et comme il a
beaucoup d'argent ça lui donne un
pouvoir plus important que ce qu'il est
en raison de cette manne financière
allez je vous donne la parole dans un
instant mais vous vouz inter rebondir
sur sur justement cet aspect religieux
idéologique parce que et parce que on a
quand même là largement mis en exerg il
me semble la dimension très opportuniste
de la diplomatie et des choix politiques
qui sont faits par le Qatar d'ailleurs
c'est quand même intéressant C citation
qu'on a pour les pour qualifier cette
monarchie est-ce qu'elle est O habit
est-ce qu'on est sur une mouvance sur la
mouvance frériste parce que on a quand
même aussi beaucoup parlé bien sûr des
liens du catar avec les farmes musulman
si vous me demandez moi je pense qu'ils
sont tout à fait opportunistes en
réalité qu'on est plutôt sur un islam
traditionnel qui fait le choix de
certaines tendances plus idéologisées
type Frères musulmans type groupe
salafiste en Syrie pour des pour des
raisons purement opportunistes qui nous
en fait qui nous ramènent dans le golf
et aux rivalités
entre entre l'Arabie saoudite le Qatar
les Émirats arabunis oui c'est une
dictature oui alors d'ailleurs non mais
c'est intéressant parce que par exemple
quand on quand vous dites enfin on a
plusieurs lectures de la question moi je
ne pense pas par exemple du tout que le
Qatar a financé des association
caritative salafiste qui indirectement
pouvait prêter main fort main forte
pardon à des à des organisation
djihadistes pour des raisons religieuses
moi je ou ou ou des raisons liées à la
nature du régime de Bachar l'assade vous
savez il y a cette cette cet argument
selon les lequel en gros il faudrait
lutter contre ces anciennes dictatures
arabes laïqu moi je pense que c'est
simplement vraiment on est dans les
rapports de force de pouvoir et que le
et que ces pays du Golf a pas forcément
une intention d'imposer un modèle euh
religieux on va dire hérité du du
wahabisme Islam très rigoriste un peu
partout sur la planète parce que c'est
ce qu'on peut prêter aux Frères
musulmans comme intention oui non c'est
vrai c'est une dimension mais je pense
que l'islam si ou aujourd'hui est
tellement fragmenté fragmentaire on a
une telle implosion en fait des
référents et cetera que à mon sens mais
encore une fois c'est ma lecture on est
plus encore une fois sur des rapports de
force de pouvoir géopolitique que sur
des intentions lié à des doctrines ou
des alignements idéolog il nous reste
toute la partie parce que c'est c'est
pour ça que ce débat est passionnant
toute la partie lien avec avec nous quoi
avec les les pays occidentaux et et
toute la la partie on va dire
investissement et business mais je
voudis un dernier mot quand même sur ce
euh ce ce premier chapitre est-ce qu'on
sait comment le Qatar a réagi à
l'attaque du terroriste du Hamas le le 7
octobre c'estd est-ce que ils ont été
surpris est-ce que il
il ils pensent que le Hamas est allé
trop loin et que finalement il complique
la tâche de est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
est-ce que peut-être il y a pas de
réponse à cette question hein mais c'est
difficile à dire on est pas dans le
secret des dieux donc on va il y a pas
eu de réponse officielle il y a pas eu
de pas surinterpréter les réaction
officielle et puis surtout personne ne
sait ce qui s'est dit et et surtout moi
j'entends des analystes dire le le le
Qatar n'était pas au courant ou comment
comment on sait que le Qatar n'était pas
au courant peut-être que le Qatar est au
courant je je je ne sais pas moi mais en
tout cas bon le Qatar donne 30 millions
par mois euh au Hamas pour pour les les
fris fonctionnement des des
fonctionnaires bon à un moment donné le
Qatar n'est pas non plus naïf le Hamas
étant un groupe quand même relativement
militarisé terroriste donc il savait
peut-être qu'à un moment donné ouais
déboucher sur ce genre d'action donc
c'est c'est difficile à dire votre avis
là-dessusalois je je recite pour les
spectateurs qui ont vu la première
partie de l'émission On va un peu se
répéter mais c'est important cet article
du Monde qui reprend des éléments des
services de renseignement américains qui
auraiit donc débriffer le leurs
homologues occidentaux avec un un
certain nombre d'informations évidemment
à prendre avec prudence on l'a expliqué
tout à l'heure voilà c'est une
communication de service de de
renseignement mais qui dit notamment que
la branche politique du Hamas aurait ét
était tenu à l'écart de la préparation
des attaques terroristes est-ce que
c'est on l'a évoqué en première partie
est-ce que c'est une façon de protéger
peut-être l'allié qui est le Qatar mais
justement j'allais rebondir sur ce que
vient dire quentin Müller à ce propos
parce qu' il y a quand même deux
branches au sein du Hamas il y a la
branche politique et il y a la branche
militaire la branche politique est
abritée à à Doha enfin la tête de la
branche politique est abritée à à Doha
et effectivement moi j'ai eu plusieurs
information selon lesquelles la branche
politique avait été tenue à l'écart
puisque la branche politique elle mesure
beaucoup mieux si je puis dire les
conséquences d'une telle action
militaire menée contre Israël avec tous
les les drames qui s'en sont suivi et la
réaction évidemment d'Israël qui était
extrêmement violente et qui peut faire
se retourner contre le Hamas toute une
partie de la population de la bande de
Gaza qui subit ce déluge de feu donc moi
cette distinction je la fais volontiers
entre le politique et l' militaire même
si de nombreuxes analystes ne sont pas
d'accord avec ça estimant que c'est une
seule organisation et ce qui me fait
dire que c'est probable que le la
branche militaire politique savait
peut-être que quelque chose se préparait
mais sûrement pas de sa tempampleur
quand on voit que le secret a été aussi
bien gardé quand on voit l'ampleur de
l'opération le nombre de combattants qui
ont été associés à cette opération et
que rien n'a filtré avant l'opération
qui a évité enfin qui a pas permis une
réaction à la hauteur de ce qui se
préparait pour moi ça va tout à fait
dans le sens du fait que la branche
politique n'était pas elle c'est
peut-être au courant que il y avait des
actions militaire parce que ça il en a
souvent eu et c'est pas ça sera pas la
première de cette ampleur moi je suis
persuadée que elle était pas au courant
et je suis persuadé d'une autre chose
mais on sort peut-être un peu c'est que
les les combattants eux-mêmes du Hamas
quand ils sont sortis en Israël ils ont
été étonnés de voir qu'il y avait aussi
peu de de de présence militaire
israélienne et je suis alors convaincu
d'une chose je ne peux évidemment pas le
démontrer que c'est allé bien au-delà de
ce que eux-mêmes avaient imaginé et du
coup ben vous vous lancez des des des
des gens qui sortent de la bande de Gaza
et c'est absolument pas pour justifier
je prends toutes les précautions qu'il
le faut hein je ne justifie en rien ce
qui s'est passé mais une espèce de folie
qui s'est emparée aussi et a conduit à
des exations dramatiques mais je pense
que tout ça à mon avis il y a aussi eu
un enchaînement et maintenant ben il
faut que le le Hamas politique essae de
gérer la situation et c'est ingérable en
raison du massacre qui a été commis en
Israël allez je reprends la main pardon
parce que le temps affilé je voudrais
vraiment qu'on on aborde maintenant les
liens entre le le Qatar et et les pays
occidentaux notamment en matière
d'investissement tiens on va écouter
pour lancer ce chapitre le député
européen LR
brissortefeu le Qatar comme vous savez
est un grand investisseur oui bah il
investit dans notre pays un peu plus de
25 milliards
d'euros nous ne sommes pas d'ailleurs
les seuls bien bien au contraire puisque
nous avons à peu près la même proportion
d'investissements Catari en Allemagne et
en France donc les deux principales
puissances de l'Union européenne sont à
peu près à égalité sur ce plan-là et
nous nous trouvons euh et le Qatar
investit d'abord d'abord au Royaume-Uni
donc si on regarde le continent européen
je veux dire on est pas du tout une
exception bris sortefeu invité vous
l'avez compris de la matinale de de
public CNA Mathias Arz est revenu sur ce
plateau bonsoir Mathias on va parler de
l'influence du Qatar en France oui
Thomas mais avant d'ouvrir une page
investissement qatari il est difficile
de ne pas faire un lien avec l'influence
le soft power que peuvent représenter
ses investissements et les limites que
certains politiques il voient dans nos
relations diplomatiques on l'a on l'a
entendu avec brissortefeu autre exemple
Hervé Marseille sénateur et président du
groupe Union centriste s'est exprimé sur
la question c'était le 11 octobre
dernier lors des questions d'actualité
au Gouvernement ces tueurs ils sortent
pas de nulle part ils ont été
accompagnés ils ont été aidés entraînés
fin financé et on sait par qui on sait
par qui par le Qatar puisque le chef des
tueurs esté Bergé au Qatar monsieur
anier est au Qatar ceela même qui
finance ici le PSG ou d'autres grandes
entreprises alors justement dans quoi le
Qatar investit en France et bien on va
commencer par le sport évidemment Hervé
Marseille en parlait les supporters du
PSG en savent quelque chose il y a
également le Prix de l'Arc de Triomphe
aussi pour les amateurs de course pque
il y a ensuite le luxe avec par exemple
le magasin le printemps à Paris qui
appartient au Qatar l'immobilier avec
l'hôtellerie je vais vous citer quelques
palaces passés sous pavillon de l'émirat
le Royal Monceau l'Hôtel du Louvre ou
encore l'Intercontinental et enfin le
secteur de l'énergie le Qatar compte des
pars dans le fleuron français Total
ainsi que des participations dans des
groupes comme Vincy ou la Gardère
comment on peut expliquer justifier ces
investissements alors certains
observateur il voit une diplomatie des
coulisses ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ne
s'agit pas de charité la lune de miel
comme comme beaucoup la présente remonte
à la présidence Sarkozi après être
intervenu sur la libération des
infirmières bulgares en Libye le Qatar
obtient de la France un avantage fiscal
sans pareil le pays ne payera pas
d'impôts sur les plus-values qu'il
réalisera dans l'Hexagone une relation
qui interpelle mais qui est utile dans
les deux sens comme l'explique justement
Christian Chau nous sommes allés le
rencontrer il est grand reporter
international à Radio France et auteur
de plusieurs ouvrages sur les mirirat
parfois ça peut être ça peut être
compliqué quand il commence à investir
dans l'islam de France dans des mosquées
il y avait eu avec catar charity des des
réseaux mis à jour euh mais en même
temps voilà c'est c'est pas interdit
c'est pas illégal donc après c'est une
question voilà de réciprocité c'està
dire après est-ce qu'on a un levier sur
le Qatar est-ce qu'on peut leur parler
franchement
euh mais encore une fois c'est une boîte
au LED qui est très utile parce que là
on peut parler aux Iraniens on peut
parler au Hamas donc voilà c'est un peu
la la diplomatie je veux dire de
coulisse
et là j'allais dire les catariens sont
champions du monde ouais pour rappel le
Qatar investi en France 25 milliards
d'euros c'est autant qu'en Allemagne
mais bien moins qu'en Grande-Bretagne où
DOA compte environ 45 milliards d'actifs
merci Mathias pour pour tout ces
information agè Levallois il faut
peut-être rappeler que l'Europe vient de
remplacer le gaz russe enfin en partie
par le gaz venu du Qatar est-ce que ça
ça peut
expliquer la la prudence qui va
s'exprimer dans dans les prises de
parole des différents leaders européens
dans les dans les heures ou dans les
jours qui viennent vis-à-vis de
l'éventuel je mets plein de guillemets
de de précaution responsabilité du Qatar
dans ses liens avec le Hamas le
financement et l'aboutissement à cette
opénagar on a besoin du Qatar on a
besoin des investissements du Qatar
c'est vrai que si aujourd'hui on se
fâche avec le Qatar et bien ça peut
mettre à mal certains investissements on
vend de l'armement au Qatar puisque la
France a un accord de défense avec le
Qatar et donc c'est une place forte de
de de de la de militaire française dans
la région en plus de la base que nous
avons à Abu Dhabi et donc on n' pas
envie de se priver aussi de ces avions
de ces rafales qu'on vend au Qatar qu'on
a vendu et j'imagine qu'on espère en
vendre encore donc on a besoin et
surtout ce dont on a besoin avec le
Qatar parce que le Qatar l'a démontré
c'est cette capacité de médiation je
veux dire on sait très bien que
Christian chinud qu'on vient de voir
avec George malbruno et bien ont été
libérés quand ils étaient pris en otage
en Irak et que le Qatar a joué un rôle
et on sait très bien que le athar
justement de par ses relations et bien
et on l'a vu récemment avec les otages
qui sont dans la bande de Gaza où
certains ont été deux vieilles dames
israélien hier ont été libéré grâce à la
médiation de l'Égypte et du Qatar et
c'est vrai que l'argent du Qatar là pour
le coup et bien sert aussi dans le cadre
de la Libération d'otage parce que si on
ne paye pas on sait très bien qu'il y a
quand même de l'argent qui à un moment
on a besoin de cet argent et donc le
Qatar est très pratique puisqu'on
entretient un bon dialogue avec cet
émirat et on considère donc que et bien
on doit faire affaire avec lui et qu'on
en profite d'une certaine manière quant
à müer cette cette diplomatie là
tousimite elle s vous l'avez évoqué un
tout petit peu tout à l'heure jeais bien
qu'on rentre dans le détail elle
s'explique aussi par par l'histoire le
Qatar il veut être influent pour se
protéger tous les pays de cette région
se souviennent évidemment du kit 1982 ça
fait partie de la de l'équation quoi oui
le kit en 1990 c'était un pays qui était
à politique c'est-à-dire un pays très
riche mais qui ne pensait pas justement
à avoir tout ces bonnes relations et
aménager des relations un peu partout au
MoyenOrient et y compris dans les pays
occidentaux donc à l'époque il y avait
une forte présence ouvrière
palestinienne au kouwiit et donc quand
l'Irak envahi le kwiit et Yasser Arafat
ne condamne pas l'invasion iraakienne
des des Palestiniens ont ont collaboré
avec les les soldats iraakiens et donc
le le kwait a été envahi et donc je
pense qu'il y a eu une prise de
conscience à à ce moment-là des pays du
golf en se disant premièrement la cause
palestinienne on va on va faire on va
mettre un frein là-dessus on va se
rapprocher un peu plus d'Israël parce
que l'immigration notre immigration
ouvrière arabe palestinienne et autres
égyptiennees et cetera est très politisé
et nous ça fait pas nos affaires et en
même temps il faut absolument qu'on soit
beaucoup plus proche de tout un tas de
groupuscul politisé dans les pays arabes
et également être beaucoup plus proche
et parler beaucoup plus à la communauté
internationale pour se défendre de ce de
de ce type d'invasion ouais tiens on
peut écouter sur sur justement la la
cause palestinienne une déclaration
récente de l'émire du Qatar c'était lors
de l'assemblée générale des des Nations
Unies il plaide très clairement pour la
solution à deux état il veut même
revenir à 1967 on va voir que c'est pas
si
simple la communauté internationale a la
responsabilité de trouver un accord de
paix global et juste sur la question
palestinienne en établissant un État
palestinien au côté de l'État d'Israël
sur la base des frontières de 1967 avec
Jérusalem est comme capitale ainsi qu'en
mettant fin à l'occupation des terres
arabes et en trouvant une solution juste
à la crise des réfugiés c'est ce que la
communauté internationale a convenu il y
a plusieurs décennies mais qui n'a
jamais été mis en œuvre on va pas donner
trop d'importance au Qatar ça peut être
le BI d'un débat comme comme celui-là
mais mais tout de même il là on parle
des otages c'est vrai qu' y a ce rô
laiss c'est peut-être à court terme ce
qu'on ce que beaucoup de pays
occidentaux euh attendent du Qatar
est-ce que ça peut être aussi un acteur
d'une solution politique plus global
pour pour cette région et notamment pour
les Palestiniens je je ne pense pas
c'est pas ce qu'on cite prioritairement
euh mais est-ce qu'ils peuvent y
participer mais je ne pense pas
justement du fait de de cette diplomatie
très floue très opportuniste qui
multiplie les alliances qui euh enfin le
Qatar tente en fait de parler à tout le
monde c'est bien pour ça que je pense
qu' y a pas vraiment d'idéologie où
cette idéologie ces positionnements sont
finalement très très opportunistes en
fonction des contextes des
configurations pour dire les choses plus
simplement plus simplement quand ça les
arrange bon maintenant c'est vrai qu'il
y a quand même ce potentiel de médiation
qu'on ne peut pas nier donc l'idée quand
même de et c'est on le voit he c'est
vraiment ce queessaie de faire les
États-Unis actuellement la France et
d'autres pays y compris je pense Israël
c'est d'essayer de de voilà de faire
levier et et de et de profiter de ces de
cet appui pour sauver le maximum d'otage
qui pourront l'être mais à aucun moment
le Qatar par exemple n'a parlé de d'une
d'une road map pour le proche orient
d'une relance du processus de paix n'a
jamais cherché à s'associer à une
entreprise une initiative un regain
d'initiative sur le plan multilatéral
pour relancer ce processus de paix puis
de toute façon soyons bien clair les
Palestiniens les Israéliens ne sont plus
du tout non plus dans cette logique on
va dire depuis la fin de la seconde
Intifada les accord d'Oslo sont morts il
y a pas de il y a pas il y a aucun cadre
donc cert les
américainess B les Américains ont essayé
de relancer un peu ça mais vraiment pour
des quasiment de manière cosmétique j'ai
envie de dire parce que le
positionnement est très proisraélien on
est vraiment plus du tout dans une
diplomatie américaine qui cherche à à à
trouver une issue et dans et là avec les
je crains qu'avec les événements qui
vont continuer de se développer dans les
jours et les semaines qui viennent il
faut quand même pour avoir un cadre pour
un cadre il faut avoir un des conditions
favorables là je ne vous raconte pas le
ressentiment de part et d'autrre qui va
ressortir de tout ça et ce n'est que le
début donc comment derrière penser qu'on
va pouvoir après des décennies d'échecs
relancer quelque chose facilement je je
pour ma part je n'en suis pas convaincu
he ou on va parler des relations entre
la France et le Qatar laticia qui sont
renforcé depuis 2019 avec le dialogue
stratégique France Qatar expliquez-nous
et oui ces deux pays la France et le
Qatar ont décidé de se voir
régulièrement pour pour entretenir ce
dialogue stratégique qui concerne
beaucoup de partenariats dans différents
domaines évidemment la sécurité on en a
parlé l'énergie mais aussi alors la
situation bien sûr géopolitique au
Moyen-Orient mais des domaines aussi
très précis comme la culture l'éducation
le climat la cybersécurité il y a entre
France et Qatar ce dialogue qui est
instauré la première session de ce
dialogue a eu lieu sous l'égit de
jean-udrian qui est alors ministre des
affair étrangère hein c'était en 2000 en
2022 à dois voilà donc ça cétait la
première session et alors le communiqué
qui mettait en place ce dialogue
expliquait qu'en fait c'était une façon
d'accroître la coopération de la France
et du Qatar dans des domaines
prioritaires d'intérêt muturel reste
quand même à définir ses domaines
mutuels et ses priorités mutuelle c'est
un peu une phrase tiroire en gros la
France disait au français voilà qui va
être notre allié aujourd'hui euh dans la
région ce ser il a eu des avancé
concrètes notamment sur la médecine oui
il y a eu
effectivement par exemple la proposition
de la France de former d'accueillir des
spécialistes des médecins spécialistes
cataris et de les former en France ça ça
a eu lieu hein et ça continue aussi à
d'avoir lieu et puis il y a eu aussi
beaucoup de de chantiers mis en place
avec le site le lycée Franco euh
catarien le lycée Voltaire à DOA
d'accord on ça c'est une autre question
le lycée Voltaire qui a eu subi qui
était l'établissement qui appartenait à
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
mais qui en fait avec une interférence
du procureur général qui est un une
personnage clé de l'émirat qui a voulu
changer les programmes puisque ces
programmes dans ce lycée français au
Qatar devaient respecter les programmes
français avec la question de la laïcité
et donc du coup le lycée Voltaire
aujourd'hui est complètement entre les
mains du Qatar et un autre lycée a été
réouvert mais du coup dans le cas C de
la EFE qui est cette agence de
l'enseignement du français à l'étranger
donc ça a été très problématique quand
là on voit que l'intérêt mutuel parfois
peut-être contradictoire on n pas
toujours les mêmes intérêts et là dans
le cas de ce lycée Voltaire qui était
une réussite mise en avant par la France
et le Qatar et bien ça s'est arrêté très
vite et donc c'est devenu un lycée
complètement qatarien financé par le
Qatar même si il y a des professeurs
français détachés et voilà et on on
comprend bien l'intérêt économique
Laeticia est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire l'intérêt diplomatique de ce de ce
on l'a dit hein dans dans dans ce
dialogue que nous avons là ici ce soir
l'Arabie Saoudite c'est difficile de se
rapprocher de l'Arabie Saoudite qui
s'est tourner vers les États-Unis il
faut bien que la France se trouve Thomas
un allié arabe solide elle a choisi le
Qatar et donc le Qatar lui a promis dans
ce dialogue aussi stratégique parce qu'
il est question de terrorisme il n'est
pas que question de domaine secondaire
mais le Qatar a promis à la France de
l'aider dans sa guerre contre Lesan
organisations terroriste or quand on
sait que le Qatar aide le Hamas là ça
devient un peu plus compliqué
d'expliquer où est l'intérêt de la
France notamment ça réagit pas trop pour
l'instant en France pour l'instant non
justement il faudra l'expliquer aux
Français pour l'instant l'opinion
publique est assez à ton par rapport à
ce qu'on a connu pendant la coupe du
monde pour l'instant ce dialogue
stratégique qui a eu lieu aussi avec
Catherine Colona qui était toute
nouvelle au kedorset en juin dernier
pour l'instant ça fait pas trop de de
remour on n parle pas trop c'est vrai
que c'est quand même assez discret et on
imagine que quand même l'État français a
déjà mis en place tout son argumentaire
qui expliquerait pourquoi le Qatar est
l'allié privilégié de la France enfin il
y a les Émirats aussi qui sont un allié
privilégié on a quand même une base
militaire à Abu Dhabi donc c'est vrai
que la relation avec le Qatar est forte
mais on a aussi des relations avec
d'autres pays de la région et dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme c'est vrai
que le Qatar a pris un certain nombre de
mesures pour lutter contre le
financement du terrorisme en prenant
vraiment des mesures et donc c'est vra
c'est ça aussi qui a été mis en avant
dans la coopération avec la France pour
dire que le Qatar particip
à vraiment l'AL par la FO on fin
desan plusou
dira même Unat schizoprè t les pays
du tous les pays du l'Arabie Saoudite
aujourd'hui c'est c'est d'une
ambivalence absolue également donc on
est dans des dans des pays qui sont tout
récents n'oublions pas le Qatar date de
1971 donc il faut tout mettre en place
donc il faut des alliances donc il faut
exister donc il faut trouver des moyens
de s'imposer et quand on dispose de
beaucoup d'argent et ben ça laisse
effectivement le champ libre a beaucoup
de possibilités j jamais l'État français
va frontalement sur ces domaines là et
et et et va parler frontalement au Qatar
en disant il y a un problème d'ambiguïé
sur ces thématique jamais mais parce que
je pense qu'il y a une question
financière vous avez évoqué l'Arabie
Saoudite la France est allié de l'Arabie
Saoudite mais financièrement le Qatar
paye plus enfin de de gros contrats que
l'Arabie Saoudite donc donc forcément il
y a une question d'interdépendance moi
j'ai j'ai en mémoire un épisode de 1997
quand le le l'émire Khalifa qui était
l'émire du Qatar était pris dans une
affaire de proxineétisme à Paris à
l'hôtel carillon son son nom était cité
dans une affaire et il y avait un juge
d'instruction à l'époque qui voulait
condamner l'mir du Qatar pour une
affaire de proximitisme et à l'époque
l'état l'État français avait recadré ce
jus d'instruction et avait mis la faire
dans un placard pourquoi parce que il y
a cette relation
d'interdépendance financière entre entre
le le le Qatar et la France et et et nos
politiques sont sont sont tétanisés ne
peuvent pas aller plus loin dans dans
dans dans ce rapport de force en fait
myiam benrad je voudrais qu'on termine
on l'a évoqué mais peut-être un peu trop
rapidement quand même sur le le le rôle
que le Qatar mène actuellement
euh pour obtenir éventuellement des des
libérations euh d'otage
euh il payent pour ça pardon de poser
une question très très trsi je pense que
c'est oui oui je pense qu'il on peut pas
exclure qu'il ait une dimension
financière à la négociation bon
maintenant le le Hamas reçoit quand même
beaucoup d'argent du Qatar depuis un
certain temps donc le Qatar a forcément
euh un poids euh enfin est en mesure de
négocier ce que d'autres ne pourront pas
négocier maintenant je pense que le
Hamas
euh va monayer les otages hein pour moi
il y a aucune aucun doute ouais us parce
que pour l'opinion publique c'est c'est
difficilement euh audible oui le Qatar a
des leviers effectivement dans sa
relation privilégiée qu'il a avec le le
Hamas et même si le le Qatar n'a pas
forcément été au courant de tous les
détails de cette opération qui s'est
déroulé opération dramatiqu mais il a
des moyens aujourd'hui à travers ses
relais sur place quand même de pouvoir
essayer de négocier obtenir la
libération d'otage et ce qui lui
permettrait de se présenter de montrer
qu'effectivement il a ses leviers dont
que d'autres pays n'ont pas et ça lui
donne un poids je reviens toujours à
cette cette idée du Qatar qui doit
exister tous les moyens sont bons et là
si dans cette ce drame là il peut
permettre faciliter la la libération
d'un certain nombre d'otages ça lui
donne un poids diplomatique bien au-delà
de ce qu'il représente et donc c'est ça
aussi toute cette stratégie qui est mise
en place par le Qatar et qui pour
l'instant lui ré n'oubliez pas les
négociations avec les Américains pour
l'Afghanistan avec les talibans se sont
passées au Qatar et donc tout le ou a
une représentation encore aujourd'hui
des talibans au catar et le retrait des
Américains de d'Afghanistan s'est fait à
travers des négociation que le Qatar
organisait à Doha avec les talibans et
les Américains c'est ça la la
spécificité plus que les autres pays du
Golf que le Qatar veut vraiment
entretenir pour montrer qu'il est
incontournable indispensable se rendre
indispensable merci à tous d'avoir
particip à ce débat je vais rappeler les
titres de vos livres myrian bemrade on a
islamique est-il des fait aux éditions
CNRS et puis Quentin müer les esclaves
de l'homme pétrole aux éditions martiali
merci encore je vous dis à à demain pour
un nouveau numéro de de sens public on
se retrouve à 18h et 22h comme chaque
jour sur Public Sénat et puis notez que
l'invité de la matinale 8h demain matin
Orian mansini reçoit l'ancienne
ambassadrice Sylvie Berman belle
soirée